[Music]
which of these entities has evolved the
ability to manipulate an animal many
times its size the answer is all of them
these are all parasites organisms that
live on or inside another host organism
which they harm and sometimes even kill
parasites survival depends on
transmitting from one host to the next
sometimes through an intermediate
species our parasites elegantly achieve
this by manipulating their hosts
behavior sometimes through direct brain
hijacking for example this is the
Gordian worm one of its hosts this
cricket the Gordian worm needs water to
mate but the cricket prefers dry land so
once it's big enough to reproduce the
worm produces proteins that garble the
crickets navigational system the
confused cricket jumps around
erratically moves closer to water and
eventually leaps in often drowning in
the process the worm then wriggles out
to mate and its eggs get eaten by little
water insects that mature colonize land
and are in turn eaten by new crickets
and thus the Gordian worm lives on and
here's the rabies virus another
mind-altering parasite this virus
infects mammals often dogs and travels
up the animals nerves to its brain where
it causes inflammation that eventually
kills the host but before it does it
often increases its hosts aggressiveness
and ramps up the production of rabies
transmitting saliva while making it hard
to swallow these factors make the host
more likely to bite another animal and
more likely to pass the virus on when it
does and now meet Ohio cordyceps also
known as the zombie fungus its hosts of
choice is tropical ants that normally
live in treetops
after Ohio cordyceps spores Pierce the
ants exoskeleton they set off
convulsions that make the ant fall from
the tree the fungus changes the ants
behavior compelling it to
wander mindlessly until it stumbles onto
a plant leaf with the perfect fungal
breeding conditions which it latches on
to the ant then dies and the fungus
parasitosis its body to build a tall
thin stalk from its neck within several
weeks the stalk shoots off spores which
turned more ants into six legged leaf
seeking zombies one of humanity's most
deadly assailants is a behavior altering
parasite though if it's any consolation
it's not our brains that are being
hijacked I'm talking about Plasmodium
which causes malaria this parasite needs
mosquitos to shuttle it between hosts so
it makes them bite more frequently and
for longer there's also evidence that
humans infected with malaria are more
attractive to mosquitoes which will bite
them and transfer the parasite further
this multi species system is so
effective that there are hundreds of
millions of malaria cases every year and
finally there are cats don't worry there
probably aren't any cats living in your
body and controlling your thoughts I
mean probably but there is a
microorganism called Toxoplasma that
needs both cats and rodents to complete
its life cycle when a rat gets infected
by eating cat feces the parasite changes
chemical levels in the rats brain making
it less cautious around the hungry
felines maybe even attracted to them
this makes them easy prey
so these infected rodents get eaten and
passed the parasite on mind-control
successful there's even evidence that
the parasite affects human behavior in
most cases we don't completely
understand how these parasites manage
their feats of behavior modification but
from what we do know we can tell that
they have a pretty diverse toolbox
Gordian worms seem to affect crickets
brains directly the malaria parasite on
the other hand blocks an enzyme that
helps the mosquitoes feed forcing them
to bite over and over and over again the
rabies virus may cause that snare
slobbering behavior by putting the
immune system into overdrive
but whatever the method when you think
about how effectively these parasites
control the behavior of their hosts you
may wonder how much of human behavior is
actually parasites doing the talking
since more than half of the species on
earth are parasites it could be more
than we think
you
[Music]